how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
congratulations marvel fans
we did it we survived a whole year and a
half
without any new marvel shows or movies
and now we are finally in phase four and
phase four got started off with a two
episode premiere
of the brand new wanda vision disney
plus series from marvel studios
now a lot happened within these two
episodes including what i believe to be
the reveal of not one not two but three
villains for the one division series
villains that i believe
can kind of explain what exactly is
going on in this very weird
television show so i'll break down what
i think is happening within the one
division series and why these villains
want wanda when the series starts we can
see that vision is all of a sudden
alive and him and wanda are recently
married
they drive into their new town to their
new home there's a lot of comedy
involved in the first scenes and a lot
of references to old sitcoms including
bewitched
and the dick van dyke show vision
disguises himself as a human and then
heads off to work then immediately
agnes comes to the door now agnes is
kind of a mysterious character at this
point
she invites herself into wanda's house
and asks her a ton of questions
now i believe this to be agatha harkness
a witch from the salem witch trials who
has a heavy connection to wanda in the
comics
now agatha has been both good and bad
she's been a mentor to wanda in the
comics but she could be
a villain in this show based off of what
i've seen in the first three episodes
i'm not 100 sure so i'm not going to
classify her as one of the three
villains
but either way she knows who wanda is
wanda and vision have a bit of a
misunderstanding about an important date
marked on the calendar
wanda believes it to be her anniversary
with vision when in reality
vision's boss mr hart is coming over for
dinner meanwhile
wanda prepares for a romantic night mr
and mrs hart come over and we hear a
sakovia reference
where wanda is from which i believe is
going to be a heavy factor
moving forward in the one division
series wanda prepares dinner and up
until this point everything seemed kind
of
normal until mr hart starts choking
the show then becomes a little bit of a
horror show and a very creepy scene that
takes place
mr hart is choking and nobody is helping
him in fact his wife just sits there and
says stop it
but it's almost like she's saying stop
it to wanda
and not her husband eventually wanda
tells vision to help him and vision
saves his life
and then in a very weird turn of events
they act like nothing has happened
and they just leave now there are some
major and important things that you need
to note about what happens during these
scenes
one is that when wanda is cooking dinner
she invites agnes over for help
agnes at that point kind of refuses to
leave wanda tries very
very hard to get her to go without
success until finally getting her to
leave
but she ends up coming back through the
front door it seems like she can't leave
wanda and vision alone
another important thing to note that
ties into what i believe to be the main
villain of not only this series but
phase 4 and phase 5 of the mcu
is that mr and mrs hart start asking
juan to envision some questions about
when they got married
where they moved from but specifically
why they don't have any kids
wanda envisioned not having any kids is
going to be a main factor of
the main villain which i believe is
revealed in episode 2 so i'll talk about
that in just a second
wanda and vision can't actually answer
these questions
they don't know they don't know when
they got married they don't know where
they moved from and they don't know
their story
which is very very odd and when mr and
mrs hart
leave wand and vision talks more about
how it is odd that they don't know their
anniversary
where they moved from or what their
story is but then it gets even more
strange when we find out that an agent
of sword
is watching them like a tv show on a
television
now if you're not familiar with what
sword is it is the space
counterpart to shield sword stands for
sentient
world observation and response
department and they seem to be
monitoring wanda and vision
now things start to really pick up in
episode 2 where there are references and
easter eggs to three
villains the first one is actually
spotted in the intro of episode 2
right after the funny bed scene opening
if you pause the show
during the intro at 3 27 when vision
is phasing through the floor you can see
that under the floor
is a helmet of some sort now originally
a lot of us thought that this was
galactus helmet however this looks a lot
more like
the grim reaper's helmet this is villain
number one
and what's really interesting about this
is that grim reaper in the comics
is the brother of wonder man and
basically what happens in the comics is
that vision's brainwaves came from
wonder man so grim reaper views vision
as an abomination that stole a part of
his brother
now another really interesting thing
about grim reaper is that at one point
in time he has worked for hydra
and ultron and i'll go over that in just
a bit when we talk about the hydra scene
in episode 2.
as we get into this episode we see that
wanda and vision are doing a talent show
that is for the children and this is an
ongoing theme
from here wanda goes off to the planning
committee meeting for the talent show
and vision goes off to a neighborhood
watch meeting but before wanda goes out
we see that she finds a helicopter
a helicopter that is in color red and
yellow and it has
the sword logo on it now it was revealed
in the first episode that sword is
indeed
monitoring her and we have seen from the
trailers that there's a helicopter that
looks exactly like this that kind of
gets sucked into
this magical bubble that is surrounding
west view so this is that helicopter and
eventually we will see the scene where
it gets sucked into this reality
but wanda is starting to realize that
things aren't quite what they seem
and things are getting a little weird
but here is where we get
possibly the biggest easter egg and
reveal and hint
towards who the villain of the show
actually is
during the planning meeting the
character dottie says
the devil is in the details bev and then
agnes
again who we believe to be agatha
harkness
leans over to wanda and says that's not
the only place he is
now for those of you who have been
watching my videos leading up to one
division
you know what i'm about to say this is a
reference to
mephisto mephisto is the devil
of the marvel universe he is the ruler
of the hell realm
and he has a huge tie-in to wanda
specifically when it comes to her
children and children
are being stressed in this episode and
the house of m
story remember marvel does everything
super
intentionally and you're not just going
to drop the devil's name
and then a one-liner like that from
agatha immediately after without it
meaning something now this episode goes
on to stress
for the children it stresses children
and then at the end of this episode
wanda is suddenly pregnant now how
exactly is this possible since
vision is a synthesiod well in the
comics wanda is actually pregnant with
the shards of mephisto's soul and
eventually
after wanda has her kids mephisto wants
those shards
back and he ultimately would take them
back
wanda loses her kids this leads her to
eventually
go insane and it leads us up to the
house of m
storyline where she utters the famous
words no more mutants
from there she creates her own reality
where her family
is the rulers and i believe that that is
what we are working up to here
in fact we did get a little bit of a
house of m
vibe specifically at the end of this
episode when wanda and vision find out
that they're pregnant they hear a noise
outside
this is where things start to get that
horror aspect again and get very creepy
they go outside and in the street the
beekeeper comes out of the sewer
wanda gets scared and sees how this
could jeopardize her perfect
reality and she says no and then
she alters reality she changes reality
to where that person
never existed he didn't come into the
picture after they found out that
they're pregnant
now this pretty much mirrors the comics
where wanda says
no more mutants and then changes reality
in the show
she says no and then changes reality
so we know that a house of m story is
kind of taking place
within this episode and future episodes
now marvel doesn't exactly
copy the entire story from the comics
they take pieces of the story and make
their own
so it's not going to be exactly the same
but one thing is for certain
and that is that mephisto wants wanda to
have kids
however why that is is unclear at this
point but let's not forget that in the
loki trailer we did see a mephisto
easter egg in one scene in the trailer
we can see a stained glass
devil there's no real reason for marvel
to put this
in a show or a scene without it meaning
something and mephisto is too big of a
villain to just have for one
show which is why i say not only is he
going to be the big villain of this
series along with grim reaper and hydra
but he's going to be the villain of the
entire phase 4 and
possibly phase 5 appearing in other
shows and then a movie
now going back to hydra we do have this
hydra scene in this episode which is a
callback to how wanda got her powers
the easter egg 4 hydra comes in the form
of a commercial
that is a strucker hydra watch now
strucker if you recall
in avengers age of ultron is baron von
strucker
the hydra scientist who experimented on
wanda and quicksilver
and is responsible for giving them their
powers through the mind stone of course
but this most likely isn't a simple
callback hydra most likely has something
to do with the wandevision series and i
believe
that this beekeeper that came out of the
ground could be a hydra
agent somehow wanda is locked inside of
this bubble reality we've seen from the
trailers that there is clearly some type
of force field that is created by energy
protecting the city and the fact that
this person comes from
under the ground through a sewer could
mean that this was the only way that he
could
actually get through this energy field
was to go under it
now why exactly is this person a bee
keeper that's unclear right now
it could be that he is actually a
villain from the spider-man comics
the villain swarm now swarm's real name
is fritz
von mayer and he's a german scientist
who worked for adolf
hitler so they could change his story
just a little bit in the marvel
cinematic universe to make it to where
he's a hydra scientist
and this could be him that we see in
this episode but
at the same time it could very well be a
sword agent who is trying to break into
this reality
and see what's going on and try to help
wanda and i always say try and help
wanda and not want to envision because i
truly believe
that vision is not alive it's too early
to tell but i don't think he's back from
the dead
he could possibly be an illusion or he
could be the product of
mephisto we'll have to wait for more
episodes until we find out what exactly
is going on but those are the three
villains that i think were revealed in
the first
two episodes of wanda vision let me know
what you thought about the first two
episodes of wandavision in the comments
down below and let me know what you
think about these three villains
being in one division more breakdowns of
the first two episodes coming later on
this week so don't forget to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof